lohan al primer ministro británico boris
johnson le ha salido un opositor
inesperado el miércoles la cámara de los
comunes rechazó una iniciativa de los
laboristas para que los niños más
necesitados tengan comedor escolar
gratuito desde navidad hasta semana
santa una negativa que ha contado con la
oposición de marcus ransford futbolista
inglés que combina el liderazgo del
manchester united con la lucha por la
dignidad de la infancia
estoy seguro que muchos de los que
hablan de forma tan insensible sobre el
problema es porque definitivamente nunca
han vivido algo así así que yo dedicaré
mis días con la esperanza de que
empecemos a ver mejoras en el futuro
para las personas que lo necesitan más
con fútbol de todo tipo para venir tras
recoger 300.000 firmas para exigir al
gobierno que extienda las becas comedor
ransford ha cambiado el 10 por el mono
de trabajo y está ayudando en comedores
benéficos él fue un estudiante becado y
no quiere que ningún niño se quede sin
comida por eso desde el miércoles ha
conseguido que cientos de restaurantes
ingleses suplan la falta de
acción del gobierno mientras rivales
como jürgen klopp entrenador del
liverpool se rinden a su lado
en defensa fue un niño que creció en
circunstancias difíciles bendecido con
un talento sensacional y obviamente
nunca olvidó sus raíces ni de dónde
viene que tenga que hacer esto es un
poco vergonzoso pero también maravilloso
entonces espero que su madre esté
realmente orgullosa de él madres reed y
broadway su lucha e inició con la
llegada de la pandemia y desde marzo
consiguió recaudar más de 26 millones de
dólares llegando a 3 millones de niños